c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
qu'est ce que j'ai fait à cet été oui je
vais partir un peu en sicile fin juillet
du côté de du côté de la méditerranée
côte d'azur début août et après le sait
pas après je sais pas encore le roi
devrait dépendre de mon de mes finances
en tête s'il reste des branches martin
corp
alors tout d'abord je vais rentrer chez
moi à pyla-sur-mer objet d'une maison et
je vais me reposer profiter de ma maison
ou retrouver mes amis inviter des amis à
la maison ça c'est un grand plaisir
chaque été et après je partirai une
petite semaine au festival de ramatuelle
près de saint-tropez où il ya des
spectacles il ya notamment francis
cabrel le 2 août il ya des pièces de
théâtre à voir dans un beau théâtre de
verdure de ramatuelle il en plein air je
terminerai par le concert de julien
clerc toi c'est à la fois boulot plaisir
soleil farniente voilà il perd près
retour au pyla parce que c'est quand
même à l'endroit que je préfère au monde
c'est le bassin d'arcachon
[Musique]